Picture this: a businessperson.
What do you see?
A grey suit in an office job?
A former advertising agent who quit her job
to be a freelance YouTuber?
Maybe you picture someone who looks like you.
Or maybe you don’t.
But when it comes down to it -- everyone’s
a businessperson.
Like, have you ever decided on a chore schedule
with roommates?
That’s a negotiation.
Have you told someone about yourself on a
first date? I know it's uncomfortable.
But, that’s an elevator pitch.
Have you organized a bar crawl and made sure
your friends all got home in one piece?
You’ve planned an event and held a management
position.
So in this series, we’re going to help you
hone those day-to-day business skills, look
for a job, get along with your coworkers,
and really take your career to the next level.
We’re not turning you into a ‘business
robot.’ I mean, do I look like a suite? No.
We want you to succeed on your own terms and
identify what works best for you.
As they say in the business world, we’re
here to help you “capitalize on your core
competency” -- or use what makes you special
to really strut your stuff!
And before anything else, we need to sit
down and have a chat about trust.
I’m Evelyn from the Internets, and this
is Crash Course Business: Soft Skills.
[Theme Music Plays]
Trust may seem like a basic idea, but it’s
actually a challenging and fundamental concept
like the bottom level of a business pyramid.
Not a pyramid scheme.
Trust forms the basis for your reputation,
which is the foundation of working relationships,
promotions, and job offers.
Your decisions about whom to trust are affected
by how confident you are in someone, as well
as what you know about them and your experiences
with them.
How have they acted?
What have they said?
What kinds of decisions have they made?
If you’re planning a road trip, who would
you trust to navigate and also make a fire
playlist: Your best friend who you’ve gone
to concerts with since high school, or her
roommate who blasts techno and wrecked his
car last Tuesday?
When you trust someone with your AUX cord,
your car, or your career dreams, you’re
being vulnerable.
And when you start a new job, you’re trusting
that organization to treat you fairly as much
as they’re trusting you to do the work.
Trust can also make or break professional
relationships.
When a team is running smoothly, coworkers
rely on one another to get their jobs done.
But if you don’t trust someone, it can create
an imbalance of work, or you might feel like
you have to double-check everything they do.
And that can make for a rough work environment.
Lack of trust can even close the door on opportunities.
If people don’t see you as trustworthy,
they won’t want you on their team or suggest
you for that promotion.
So how do you decide who’s trustworthy,
and what can you do to make others trust you?
Now, I do not have all the answers.
But I can tell you that there are a few
different kinds of trust, like cognitive,
dispositional, and emotional.
They all blend together to form a picture
of how trustworthy someone actually is.
It’s like a trust and reputation smoothie,
y’all.
Trusting or not trusting someone for rational
reasons is known as cognitive trust.
And what do you look for when you’re analyzing
a person’s character?
It’s elementary, my dear Watson.
You need evidence!
That’s why it’s important for your hard
work to be seen by others.
Your reputation can’t improve if people
don’t know what you’ve been up to.
To build up cognitive trust, you can focus
on its three basic elements: competence, intent,
and integrity.
Let’s imagine you’re paying off those
soul-crushing student loans and take up a
side-hustle at a local coffee shop.
[Too real?]
First up is competence -- are you capable
of doing the things that your employer needs?
Can you make an extra-hot, double foam, non-fat
caramel macchiato, with two pumps caramel
and one pump cinnamon dolce, in under 3 minutes
flat?
Or are you going to give up during the morning
rush and slap down a plain black coffee with
a misspelled name.
[It’s Evelyn with a V and a Y.
Not Ellen or anything else.
I’m salty.]
If you want to build your competence, think
about how to demonstrate what you can do,
hone your skills, and acknowledge your shortcomings
so you can work on them.
Find new ways to showcase your work, or take
classes to build skills -- like a workshop
on latte art.
And if you don’t have the time or money
to sign up for something official, you can
keep watching free educational content on
YouTube.
Next up is intent -- are you looking out for
others’ interests, as well as your own?
Intent is sort of on a sliding scale.
You’re generally not taking a job for incredibly
pure or nefarious reasons.
Maybe you mainly just want to be able to pay
rent.
And that’s okay!
If your interests align with someone else’s,
you can work together.
Although one of you may be less invested.
So while you’re probably not going to be
begging your boss to explain how the coffee
beans are farmed, ground, and shipped, you
can still demonstrate intent.
Show genuine concern for others, be tactful,
and help your coworkers.
Chatting with them or doing favors like picking
up an extra shift can help build your reputation.
Finally, there’s integrity -- can you talk
the talk and walk the walk?
Do you show up to your 5am shifts and open
the store, make sure the tables are set, and
write the daily special with a pun on the
chalkboard?
Or do you show up late and forget to spell-check
“frappuccino”?
It's okay, it's hard.
Remember that consistency matters.
Doing an amazing job 90% of the time and falling
flat 10% of the time is sometimes worse than
doing an acceptable job all the time.
Little mistakes can make a big impact on your
integrity, so follow through with what you
say you’re going to do.
A helpful trick is under-promising and over-delivering.
If you’ve ever started something last-minute,
you’ll know that it takes longer than
you expect to get things done.
So manage your time wisely, and don’t deliver
half-baked work or miss your deadlines.
It kills cognitive trust.
These three parts of cognitive trust are like
the legs of a tripod.
If one’s missing, trust collapses and you’ve
got a mess on your hands.
But just because you’ve done your best
to make sure your tripod can stand on its
own, doesn’t mean you’ll immediately earn
someone’s trust.
Like we mentioned earlier, cognitive trust
is only one ingredient in this trust smoothie
-- although it’s a big one.
There’s also dispositional trust: a person’s
baseline level of trust in others.
Some people will trust you automatically,
while others take a bit more time and evidence.
To see what I mean, let’s go to the Thought
Bubble!
Imagine you’ve just joined a fashion magazine
as a junior assistant to the editor-in-chief,
and you don’t know if you’re meeting her
expectations.
Your boss is hard to read, and she keeps giving
you menial work like picking up her dry cleaning.
You want to help out with the fall fashion
show in Paris, but you’re not sure she trusts
you enough.
So let’s go back to our tripod.
You were hired with a gleaming resume and
great recommendations, and show up with her
coffee in hand every morning -- so you’re
obviously competent.
You care about the magazine’s reputation
and applied because you love writing, so your
intent is good.
And you’ve shown this intent by protecting
your boss from embarrassment at charity functions.
Despite her doubts, you consistently achieve
her impossible last-minute demands, like a
signed first edition of The Deathly Hallows.
And that shows some stellar integrity.
So what gives?
Well, your boss may just have low dispositional
trust.
Like we said, trust involves vulnerability,
which involves risk.
So dispositional trust is tied to an idea
called risk aversion -- or how much you avoid
risks.
It’s not particularly bad to have high or
low risk aversion.
But, like anything, there needs to be balance.
Having high risk aversion can protect you
from being exploited, but too much can stunt
your relationships.
And having low risk aversion may open up more
opportunities, but if you’re too trusting
you could easily be taken advantage of.
So, your boss might think that taking a chance
on a journalist fresh out of college is an
uncomfortably high risk, and have low dispositional
trust.
And you just have to try not to take it personally
and give it time.
Be conscious of how others perceive your actions,
do your job well and consistently, and build
your reputation.
You don’t need to overwork yourself -- work
smart, not just hard.
And if you can go above and beyond by getting
ahead of deadlines, that’s great!
Before you know it, you’ll be helping with
the next big project.
Thanks, Thought Bubble!
Now, let’s say you’re great at your current
job.
You’ve shown competence, intent, integrity
and jumped over dispositional trust hurdles
to build your reputation.
That doesn’t mean you’ll be trusted in
every situation.
Trust also depends on the circumstance.
A competence mismatch is when someone may
trust your skills in one area, but not others.
For example, you might trust an actor to deliver
high-quality entertainment.
But no matter how well they played a loveable
but crotchety E.R. doctor, you wouldn’t
trust them with your knee surgery.
An intent mismatch is if you might help someone
in one way, but not others.
Like, you might ask the English major down
the hall who roots for a rival basketball
team to read over your essay.
But you’re not going to ask her to seed
your picks for March Madness.
Building trust in all these ways can take
years of time and effort, so it’s important
to protect your reputation and act professionally
in all your jobs.
Treat others with R-E-S-P-E-C-T, hold yourself
to high standards, and think about how your
actions will be perceived.
But it’s okay to make mistakes.
We’ve all shown up late to work some point,
or had to ask for an extension on a deadline.
Like I’ve said before, no one is perfect.
And if you have a solid track record of delivering
on promises, you’ll have earned a stock
of idiosyncrasy credits.
Think of these credits as a sort of bank account,
but for trust.
Improving your reputation adds credits, but
you’ve got to pay for your mistakes.
Serious mistakes can quickly drain your account,
while smaller mistakes can be built back up
with patience, time, and careful attention
to spending.
So, hopefully you have a positive balance
and some credits saved up for when you need
them.
Because if you want to do anything in the
business world, you first need to understand
and build trust.
If you remember nothing else from this episode,
here are some key takeaways:
Trust is the building block of all relationships.
It’s tricky to navigate, and involves risk.
Pay attention to how your actions are perceived
and make sure they’re being recognized.
Building your reputation takes time and effort,
but it pays off.
Cognitive trust can be earned from competence,
intent, and integrity, so use that to place
your trust in the right people and earn the
trust of others.
But, like we said, cognitive and dispositional
trust are just part of the puzzle.
Next time, we’ll talk about how emotions
can influence trust, and what else you can
do to make sure you’re trusting people for
the right reasons.
Crash Course Business is sponsored by Google and is filmed in Missoula,
MT and it’s made with the help of all these
nice people and Thought Cafe is our amazing
animation team.
Crash Course is a Complexly production.
If you wanna keep imagining the world complexly
with us, you can check out some of our other
channels like SciShow, and delve into the
scientific subjects that defy our expectations
and make us even more curious!
Also, if you’d like to keep Crash Course
free for everybody, forever, you can support
the series at Patreon; a crowdfunding platform
that allows you to support the content you
love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued
support.